he has to as quickly as possible change
his brand disconnect with old whatever
happened get that stuff situated lawyers
where you made money whatever you did
make it good with everybody you ever
screwed whatever you did
he has to make those things good because
a big part one of the stories was like
in UK XYZ happened the reason why he
left UK because one of the girls that he
said you never paid me so you know
you're gonna I'm gonna do this and so he
left UK to go to uh Romania anyways
these are stories I don't know the full
credit bill to be honest these are fully
stories that he went to Romania if he's
gonna come back which this guy's got
he's he's like a cat he's got multiple
lives this guy's gonna come back yeah
and he's on his seventh life or sixth
life you have to change some of your
strategies and you have to figure out a
way to clean up anything from your past
by getting the right lawyers making all
the old enemies into friends and allies
and moving forward so you think there is
a so two things I want to say so you
think there is a chance for him to
redeem and I mean how do you basically
tell the government United States
government listen yeah I know I poked at
you a couple times I'm sorry number one
number two Pat you were talking about
not the government I didn't say the
government but you know what I'm talking
about he's pissed off a lot of no no but
he can't go back in Apollo you don't
apologize to the government no no no
that's what I'm saying so you think you
think it's too late for him to do that
cleanup thing that you're talking about
no it's kind of like this if you're
running for office the first thing you
got to do is call every single one of
your exes and meet with them wow you
just have to do that I don't think what
I said is anything unique you have to
meet whatever you want them say so
listen I just want to talk to you how
are you doing good
anything you're upset with me okay
anything that frustrated you tell me
where you're at okay I want to tell you
19 years ago XYZ I want to apologize
that was not cool what I did I'm truly
sorry I effed up okay you have to have
those conversations if you're running
for office you have to call family
friends enemies allies access and have
those conversations and in that moment
you're gonna know this is not gonna be
fixed and this is going to come back up
guess what I can't run for office okay
he has to treat this because what he's
doing is a form of running for office
the office he's running for is the
president of the internet he's not
running for the office of President of
you know United yeah he's running to be
the president of the internet if you're
running to be the president of the
internet you have to kind of go back and
look at some of those relationships
you've been making good and 100 you got
them because you don't walk on water
none of us do this isn't a pass at him
this is just if you're really wanting
that kind of respect and accolades you
got to make some of those calls and
those are private apologies they're not
publicly it's more important it's
one-on-one face to face it case it takes
courage to do those it's very tough to
do yes what I will say by the way great
observation president no so I I I I
actually had a conversation about this
with my good buddy Michael Sartain is
basically saying today in today's
society the eyeball attention economy
where everything's about clicks and
Views and and eyeballs and and
subscribers and all that we're in a
we're in a different time where it used
to be good versus bad USA versus the
USSR right Hulk Hogan versus The Iron
cheek like there was a clear distinction
between who was the good guy who was the
bad guy these days there's the lines are
completely blurred it's just who has the
most followers who has the most Cloud
who gets the most eyeballs and if you're
running for the president the internet
you're Andrew Tate
you know how they say like other than
like literally going to jail like I
don't care what you say about me just
spell my name right yeah everybody knows
how to spell t-a-t at this point okay so
he's
fully qualified to be president of the
internet good bad or indifferent okay
whether you're Kanye whether you're
Trump whether you're freaking Billy
McFarland from the from the uh whether
you're uh Sam bakeman freed fire
Festival guys they might have a good
freed FTX people want to know your story
the bigger that you get if birdie Madoff
were alive he'd be on a [ __ ] podcast
right now but like Bernie let's hear the
deal what you had going on yeah so fully
fully endorse what you're saying right
now well I actually just want to make an
apology it was chapter 11. okay of uh
think and growing don't make that
mistake all of my Napoleon Hill fans out
there I think of garbage like Adam
you're an idiot you're scumbag is
chapter 11. I apologize right there but
what you said is so true about sex
transmutation and it's been years since
I read this book but essentially tell me
if I'm wrong the premise was some of the
greatest men in history were absolute
like sex beasts Abraham Lincoln George
Washington Einstein Thomas Jefferson
these guys were lover boys to use that
term to a little callback right there
but they took that energy and that
passion and that like that you have as a
man and funneled it into something
positive or creative or scientific or
leadership or political aspirations or
whatever and you hope you harness that
power for greatness essentially I think
that's what you did for that 17-month
celibacy I'm working on 17 days but it's
such a powerful comment but what you
also said was actually very true about
what guys will say to women it's because
women
men fall in love with their eyes women
fall in love with their ears what does
that mean men are visual creatures right
eighty percent of the reason that a guy
dates a girl is how she looks of course
and there's 20 that's like what's her
values what's her principles what's her
age like all that but it's very very
much a looks conditional thing okay for
women falling in love with their ears
it's it's not all about looks it's about
what you do for work what's your status
what car do you drive are you a good
person do you like kittens do you help
old ladies across the street are you
funny you're creative are you a man are
you an alpha and the the the the pie
graph is actually
dispersed across the place so what does
that mean a man falls in love with his
eyes because he likes how beautiful a
woman is a man knows that he has to say
some [ __ ] 100 to impress a woman if you
were going here you were going here with
a different direction where a man uh
you're you're I think you were going
here with the past and the future men
care about a woman's past women care
more about a man's future
so if you find out that this girl you're
dating used to be a stripper or a hoe or
a cardi B type girl I don't care where
she's at today it's like I can't bring
this girl out in public if a woman finds
out that that dude used to be like
homeless like uh to had sex with a ton
of women and just was like an [ __ ]
whatever but now he's cleaned it up and
his future looks bright women will jump
all over that versus a man will not go
back and and try to relive a woman's
checkered past so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign